can you still go to your barber  if he is very racist i don't know a  barber that's not a little racist  bombers are like the most strongly  opinionated [ __ ] on the face of  the earth and anybody with a strong  opinion has some choice words to say  about certain people from certain  regions  so i'm going to say yeah absolutely in  fact i encourage it please be racist you  know i understand this question though  because this is a very white question  this question is this question is kinda  racist cause you guys think you're the  only ones that can't be racist  uh-uh you ever met a whole dominican man  no they don't like anybody no no no yeah  for sure please be racist  please